[Music]
how are you eddie you did it again
you did this last week as soon as i went
right i'm going live harris disappeared
and then you've moved again but never
mind i'll get water real fast
okay i'm just gonna go i know how long
that intro is and i'm like for god's
sake where's he gone
hello
yeah hi guys and welcome to sci trek on
citrix sunday a very warm a little bit
sweaty sunday here in the uk but um i'm
talking
to my normal american friends over here
not one but two americans do your god
save me now
i do stormy paris
it's 33 degrees where i am here in the
uk and i know that's nothing to you too
but we don't have air conditioning
so
it's wham so there's a lot of ice in my
drink to see this this afternoon yeah i
don't know if it's prime day still but
you might need to amazon one of those
little portable ac's then i'd only use
it two days of the year
so
those two days would be great days oh
yeah they would be good days they would
be good days but uh but yeah it seems
like a an expense for two to three days
of the year here in the uk this is but
it might be an investment because this
is getting more our our record here in
the uk i was just telling harris is like
37.8 i think we're on track to break it
tomorrow so um
yeah
the hard it is
celsius
i don't know how you do it but you've
got air con all right
oh
everything's here con man yeah we got
not so um i've got i i basically was
living in my car
um for two days last week i was just
like i'm just gonna go for a drive and i
thought where to i don't care there's
air conditioning in the car so
i'll be back in like four hours okay
anyway a nice midday drive
so guys before we get on to the topic of
marvel fatigue
um what have you guys been watching this
week you know so we normally start our
shows
stormy something what have you thrown
out what what's been gracing your
television this week so
finished up finally the boys and uh last
episode finished up stranger things
there you go
and
for the last
okay so you guys have all seen the last
episode of stranger things is that
correct yep what was your favorite part
about the last episode
is that a question
i like the earthquake scene i did like
the earthquake scene i thought it was
cool i went when ripping through the
town that was cool um
[Music]
go on
it's got the i i gotta go eddie eddie
eddie with metallica
oh my god exactly
maybe film history tv instrumental i'm
glad duffer brothers
heavy metal
with uh i don't know if you guys
remember frank frazetta that he did a
lot of album covers back in the 70s and
the 80s kind of like boris there's one
scene where he's standing there
right when he's getting ready to take on
the bats you know he's got his spear and
he's got a shield and it's almost right
right out of a frank frazetta painting
but honest to god the the heavy metal
guitar solo when all this shit's going
down in it in the satan apocalypse
weak i think instead
how
cool and harris you look pretty cool you
look like a cool guy you got cool hair
and a fin i don't care how cool you
think you are you could have a threesome
with pamela anson and her prime and
l mcfist in the prime and you're
thinking there i'm pretty damn cool you
ain't as cool as monster on top of that
guitar i don't care how cool you think
you are metallica intel is
peak metal i mean they said it was it
was it was just awesome have you seen
all the metallica all week they've been
wearing the um the t-shirts from the
show and they've they've been doing
little things on facebook all week
god i know how much we wish we were
munson's queen macau metallica and kate
bush
stranger things doing doing them well oh
yes
i do love that cable stuff i have to
remember
but no it's very cool
i keep telling people you know if
they're really into um
you know running down a hill wait till
they hear this woman's work by bush you
know i mean that whole that whole album
was just
awesome
but it was awesome
they've been trying to get an interview
with her and she's obviously just a
complete hermit so she's sort of like
please talk to us no i haven't been
famous for the window
three quarters like 30 years no no no no
no no
no no
she's been a hermit for years she's just
just not like being famous she was one
of those things that it was about the
music not being famous
anyway
should we get a nice check
sorry
she got a very nice chat i think she got
a quarter million dollars in royalties
the first
uh weekend
just people downloading her songs i bet
she's got air conditioning yeah
if she didn't she does now okay
so so there's one more thing on my list
of things i watched this week and i i
want to
we haven't discussed it
um
it didn't get a lot of discussion coming
up but i think it's worthy of a lot of
discussion and that is the new residence
uh resident evil series
okay i will just point out it is
excellent
i will be watching it tomorrow the uh
the actress that play uh ella
balinska i think that's our pronounced
name she plays jade wesker
and
it is and i'm not trying to riff on uh
milo jovovich she did an excellent job
on all of these but this is such a
different take
on the origin story especially in
raccoon city
and it's uh
just go watch it just just you know
invest in invest a uh an hour into the
uh
first episode the season one and just
but
holy good i it's just great it's just i
really i can't recommend it enough cool
when they do resident evil
films well they're great the first one
was brilliant when they do them badly
they're bloody awful uh
awful
um but but yeah no i was looking forward
to it they spent a lot of money on it
they did a lot of money like 18 million
dollars an episode so for netflix that's
a crap load of money
but yeah i'm watching tomorrow it's one
of those shows my wife won't watch so i
have to wait till she leaves
so i'm saying hey go do something nice
why don't you go to the spa
so i can uh watch tv
there's one other thing i watched this
week has nothing to do with wifi but a
harris may dig it
uh forever i have been wanting to watch
um and this is kind of marvelous you
know
all right i've been um wanting to watch
uh uh kaplan
chaplain yeah like the movie the movie
chaplain oh yeah it's robert downey jr
yes or no i think we had in like
92 or 94 and i've never been able to see
it just
and uh it's like almost 30 years old and
i finally you know forced myself for i
found it on hbo
watched it and it was
you know
robert downey jr has always been a great
actor he's a good actor you know and and
the uh
the whole thing
where he's doing the thing where he's
finding it it's like a toddler
but the whole scene when he's like how
did chaplin become and you know him get
in the gear and it was like all magic
and then it cuts to him going yeah
that's a load of crap that's not and
that's not what happened it was actually
loads and loads and loads of hard work i
like
this the hollywood bubble there so he's
just such a meticulous guy it's that i
love that story
him buster keaton that entire arrow of
people just says buster keaton was
terrifying watch some of those old
movies like with the scene where the
house comes down it goes through the
window and that's not
that's the trust of like stand on this
box and don't move
all right he's like
he drew the chalk probably on the ground
was like well if i die i got the chalk
ready you know and if not that was just
the place it needed to be
the other one seems when he's jumping on
he's hanging off the back of a bus isn't
it anything oh it's just some of the
some of the things that was the golden
age of hollywood but those guys were
mental
it's just like
safety exactly
to try to attempt that with a stuntman
today
that was the thing as well those guys
back in the day they were paid peanuts
really yeah compared to what the studios
were making you know mr keaton you know
he died virtually a pauper but not quite
but and it's amazing
but anyway
he was he was like right he looked
toddler he was so young
and
he was just very and also marissa tormey
um another marvel actor was in that
you know
i watched the new spider-man movie yes
thank god she's still pretty she's still
gorgeous
my cousin vinnie oh nothing ever beats
my cousin very nice yeah she doesn't
deserve an oscar for her performance in
in vinnie i think the guy might have
read the wrong name
right um but she's a great actress and
she's gorgeous
yeah what you've been watching this week
harris
you know
last week i'd watched a little bit of
too much of everything i think this
weekend
i died down a little bit uh
i think i
i must have finished something but i
know the thing that i've been like
primarily watching was uh solar
opposites i don't know if y'all know
what that is or not no i've never seen
that really
do you like rick and morty
yes
yeah oh oh then you all need to watch
solar opposites yesterday so good justin
boylan one of the two creators of rick
and morty the guy that does all the
voices he has his own hulu show called
solar opposites
and it's it's great oh it's i have seen
solo opposites i've seen advertised i've
never watched it let me just see how
much you can see three just got out
it's good it's
over here very small hint just uh just
to get the sci-fi nerd and uh all uh
intrigued about it
i will give that a go um
it just appeared from disney i'm sorry
just appeared on disney probably about
three or four weeks ago here in the uk
and i've been coming about watching it
so i'll give that a go as well i have i
didn't know this existed but yeah the
art is just
there's a
literal television series inside of the
television series that is
about
two of the aliens i won't give anything
away but two of the aliens are like
childlike so
they deal with their emotions in
different ways and one of the things
they do is they're interested in people
so they shoot people with little uh ray
guns that miniaturize them
so they in their room have put a wall
full of people and built an entire
civilization of miniature people that
feed them slim
and things like that you know what that
just does to the psyche of somebody in
there and oh it's
just a watch oh it's it's insane it's
comedy but it's it's good
there's one of the one last thing i
watched this week is the last episode
for all mankind it's on apple plus here
in the us
uh it's about the fictionalized uh race
to mars between the united states and
soviet union
the whole series started out like what
if the russians got to the moon first
and
it's just this is season
three i think it is but anyway for all
mankind still excellent still rock and
roll i suggest it highly cool
i'm gonna get my business for a month
and just binge a load of tv shows like
that but i'm not paying for any more
streaming services i pay for like four
or five already so it's like
too many to hide from the wife but uh
she's like what's this bill
so i'll tell you what i watched this
week because it is the reason why we're
doing this video today or um
the topic so i did go to watch for
london last night at the cinema i spent
about 90 quid to go and watch this film
which makes me sad thinking about it god
cinnamon tickets are expensive once
you've taken kids and they won't okay
popcorn um so i are we sorry me and
harrison boasts in this film
harris how would you say this is putting
on a spot a little bit how would you sum
up
for love and thunder in in three words
i'm a bastard
i've got them but it makes me sad to say
it because i'm i've heard this said
before and i'm i gotta agree with it but
uh and it hurts me to say it because i'm
so much of a fan of the director i love
everything he's done every single thing
he's done
but this movie was too much taika
too much time to be honest that is a
bloody good way of putting it
it is too much tank it's it's it's like
well not bloody funny
there's another three words as well
sadly considering there's constant jokes
there are some great jokes in them but
it's
they dilute each other yeah give us some
brevity with an actual like emotional
scene i don't know anything
because in the movie basically let's
start off with the rock dude whose name
has just come out my head a tiger who
does new voice yeah um so he's telling
like it's a story isn't it let me tell
you the story about the space viking so
in the first five or ten minutes it's
very much like not a very good
um oops careful joke people have been
hung for less
just
you sneak is listening people
um so
um
it's
so at the start of it it's it's almost
like a bad soap opera the language isn't
you know it's quite badly written it's
quite badly it's very wooden acting
and and things so but i i always do i
was thinking
but it's going to switch to the it's
just because that's the story that's
this isn't really happening this is like
him telling the story that's why they're
doing it like this it's going to switch
in a minute and it doesn't
all the way through it stays
bad writing but i i can only imagine
it's been done on purpose because that's
what tycho wanted
that's his style but it's just
it didn't work the substance is there
but they just like they
if you bullet point that story out it's
a great story it honestly still does a
great story
but
just the the ins
it's an insane amount of jokes it's
way too much
we'll do the whole spoiler alert thing
because if you haven't seen it we've got
i will tell you bits about the film so
spoiler alert there will be i will tell
you a bit about the film so sorry i
don't know if you just want to stick
your fingers in your ears
go right ahead
just blow it out man get it out of your
system
at one point russell crowe is doing a
city like greek accent and but he's
wearing like a roman
like skirty thing he's got like the gold
armor plate and nothing but one point
he's got to walk down some stairs and he
picks it up and he's cuz
down the stairs like like a ballerina or
something
and and russell crowe i don't know if
you noticed he's quite a large fella
he's yeah
he he likes a hamburger or two that man
so um
he you know he skips don't think and
it's just an adult oh [ __ ] sake but
it's just it's it's like you said it's
the constant
not even funny
it just gets it got boring um i did lean
into the wife for about 20 minutes in
and then this is [ __ ]
um
this and something else about the marvel
films at times the special effects were
not good
um there was a few of the effects that i
just want about you guys what you think
about recent
marvel movies and a couple of tv series
is it quantity over quality all of a
sudden
okay
harrison
before i rip into it
so what do you want to
you want to rip into this first before i
really rip into it
quantity over quality
well
sure
uh it's i mean it's it's both it's real
quality while having quantity but it's
just such a formulaic quality that we're
so used to it that we're we're desperate
to have something just stand out
anywhere and if it stands out by just
being two two two two funny i i guess
thor love and thunder does stand out in
that sense where it does
it it's it's comedy supreme in a way
just because there's so much of it
but it's once again quantity over
quality again it
instead of being a good individual
unique kind of fun film they decided to
just
double down and
you know dumb it and its characters up
but that's just kind of what it feels
like
honestly thor in this movie you'd be
amazed if he could walk through a door
without hitting himself in the face with
it he is so stupid but then turns around
and fights perfectly always
oh well yeah but
almost i mean he's like an emotional
child in in times is just thick
from
a being that is thousands and thousands
and thousands of years old would never
act like that they might be a little
asshole-ish they might be
aloof a lot but i don't think they would
legitimately be dumb
well we'll talk about the whole god
thing in a minute because that's also so
just random but we're going to store
it's just
it's stuck into it sir well following up
on what harris said the whole god thing
is like
if you notice how
ogle is portrayed
serious
[ __ ] you
yeah not gonna take any spirit off
anybody
you know
and then loki
[ __ ] you i'm not gonna take [ __ ] off
anybody and then there's thor
who is like i i it's
he's like the
pile he's like the gomer pile of the
asgard
okay does anybody remember gomer pyle
did i just really date myself here go
more pile no
harris you know who's going we're pilots
right
i couldn't tell you no more pi okay
usmc andy griffith maybe no i gotta i
got andy griffith okay gilbert okay so
there's a
goomer pile was a character on the andy
griffith show gumber pyle had a spin-off
that showed him going into the marine
corps
he oh god let me try to think of a
different analogy than gun where pile
the whole hit sheet tv show with jim
neighbors called goomber pile usmc
anyway he was he was kind of roof
and he's kind of
stupid and kind of but any but somehow
he had the heart of the platoon and he
really wasn't too when he just had a
really good north carolina thick accent
um
anyway we do pile good for kevin so
proud of him that's pile
so but anyway interesting you know odin
serious loki syrians
psychotic sometimes but syria and also
kind of dead
and uh it um
but thor is just he's gotten i mean he
was kind of serious you know in thor
you know
and then it just i don't know if he
still is recovering from
um
the attack the attack on the asgardian
ship
you know uh
and seeing so many people die at the
hands of thana i don't know if he's just
gotten just
developed this really
he's using humor or
self-defacing humor
to just cope with all still
the uh the the infinity war in the end
game
that said
the
the the the the thing i'm seeing was the
although the concerns me about the the
marvel
uh
series of films and where it's going
is we always kind of knew that we were
getting to end game during these first
20 some films
where are we going now i mean like you
know star wars episode four we knew what
we there was going to be some [ __ ] going
down in episode five we kind of you know
kind of knew what was going to go on
but
you know we knew that luke was going to
have to face down vader at some point in
time but now
we had love and thunder and some others
and
where are we going
i think we are in a rebuild phase aren't
we phase four is
you know the infinity war saga ended we
had that massive battle at the end of
that um you know it really built her
crescendo and now we're in a
a rebuild phase
and um
kevin feige says
phase five is about to be released and
we'll get more of an idea of where we're
going that we've been hinted loads like
galactus
x-men
all these sorts of things but at the
moment we haven't
by this stage in stage one we'd already
started have hints of where we were
going we thought
the whole multiverse thing was where we
were going and i think that that must be
where we're going and because at the end
of loki but um
it's it's it's it's nothing we have yeah
we don't have we don't have a sort of a
singular thing of where we're
where we're going at the moment
um from love and thunder um you know the
the god butcher was supposed to be
i thought quite a major character moving
forward that's when i heard god thought
she was in this i was like getting he's
such a good character and christian bale
was really the the one good thing about
this movie is christian bale he is
fantastic as always
and he's the only one that actually
seems to be taking the film seriously at
all
um but he is genuinely brilliant
um
but they kill him at the end he's dead
so spoiler um so that's god what you've
done and the god but was such a good
character
could he have killed another god or two
we we saw him kill one god in the first
five minutes and then
nothing else
i don't see any reason why zeus and any
of the other gods would have tried to
help he didn't seem dangerous we never
saw him kill anybody else it's all one
thing off screen and then sift with one
arm i guess
cool that whole scene was sith with one
arm
i was like you can't bring sif back in
and just like
crap on it
it's going to be stiff's fighting and we
see her that she's she's in this battle
and it's gone and then thor runs up to
her and she's only got one arm and he
says oh i want to die and go to van gaal
and he's like oh well you actually need
to die in battle to go valhalla maybe
her arms in valhalla and it's just such
a stupid scene so she's going oh okay i
suppose i better get up then but again
it's so wooden in the delivery it's just
like that could have been a genuinely
properly serious moments and he's just
sort of like [ __ ] shits it down the
toilet
it's bringing in
it's talking about a concept that is
heavily used in the film the whole
valhalla aspect of things which once
again like ever
nobody everyone that gets killed in this
film does not die korg gets killed comes
back zeus gets killed comes back
christian bale gets oh excuse me thor
mighty thor jane foster gets killed
comes back gore
he's gone oh god's just a face now isn't
he but
that was a bit like the um that was just
redoing in a different way the whole um
group thing wasn't it they're just like
oh we think he's dead and he thinks and
i know but they did that in a really
good way the way they had the sapling
and they've drawn that through the
guardians movies i actually genuinely
love that and teenager groot is one of
the funniest things in the marvel movie
in years i thought it was hilarious
but
what the rock dude he's got
a cool moment
and started to break and then he's just
like i'm still here though but it's just
his face and it turns out the only thing
that's really alive it means my face i'm
like
well i just i just i genuinely wanted to
run up and just stomp on the face and i
thought no no
actually just kill him let's just kill
him it felt like chewbacca and ryze
skywalker like yeah oh except like he's
like do that do it
it's gonna hurt but do it so it's
something has like
it's pivotal you know something that has
like this yeah would have actually had
an impact in the movie something would
have actually gone oh [ __ ] i wasn't
expecting that other than all the way
through the film you're just going
higher expertise another joke
i i just want to say you know concerning
my arm is in valhalla did your arm go to
valhalla we'd have never heard general
martok say
may your arm go to stovacore
that's the first thing you would like i
wouldn't say that
no no
it's just right and in the thing just
while we're getting on to
why this movie pissed me off so much the
whole god thing right now thor is
supposedly a god but it's always set up
that he's actually an alien um and they
just portrayed themselves as gods but in
this film they really double down on the
whole gods thing
and you know that the very first thing
with the god and he gets cut and the
gold because
they their blood is all goldy
um and and then we and we see thought he
actually goes to sort of like the
the you know the place where they all
live and there's a god for everything
and they're all there
um but they're actually like they're
really gods
you know i mean it's like there's no
there's no metaphor behind or anything
these are all in god and zeus is
supposed to be the the you know the
big man and he is a
big man
um you know and you know there's some
dressing but it's just the whole way it
was done was just stupid it was just
like they you know they they
thor is a slightly silly character but i
thought they did a really good job in
the first two movies i've just drawn it
back i've always said marvel is really
good at just stepping up to the silly
you know staying within extraordinary
without going too far
this film just sort of like went a screw
it and just danced over the line into
silly and just never looked back
and the whole thing they did a really
good
job
of grounding thor
and this film just takes a massive dump
on that and just makes it all go silly
again
which hurts because it can be funny like
ragnarok it can be
humor based and still be
heartfelt this everyone keeps saying not
everyone but i i keep seeing online that
this film's got so much heart from all
the people that really like it and
i feel like it has a lot of surface
level heart but you dig anywhere and it
just falls apart
it's trying to tell you it has has heart
thor love and thunder
[Music]
it's like a rom-com yeah it's like
it's not a rom-com but um it's just
because it's not funny um i think the
thing is it comes out it is genuinely
laugh out loud funny in places taiko tt
is a very funny guy but because there's
so much of it you come away
thinking with you know like a bitter
taste i thought that wasn't funny that
was trying too hard
but how do you go from ragnarok which is
genuinely one of my favorite marvel
movies
to love and thunder which is a movie
that annoyed me so much i'm the message
you guys go in with talking about this
tomorrow because this was just awful how
do you do that how did that happen
well my question is he went from
ragnarok to jojo rabbit
which is
have you all seen jojo rabbit that's
phenomenal it's such a great movie
well
about being humorous
it's wrong in lots and lots of ways but
yeah brilliantly done it was wrong in
lots and lots in lots of ways yeah oh
yeah
don't watch it drunk or high because you
will lose your mind
i'll take you with me
i won't watch a trunk
after those two movies i i don't see
and i guess
maybe he's hanging out with what we do
in the shadows crew a whole bunch again
which is great i love what we do in the
shadows i can't wait for tuesday um
but
they they balance i mean they're a super
comical show but and film but they
balance
it with with actual
emotion and gravitas and i don't know
this movie just lost it it had it had
inklings of it every time i guess thor
and jane were starting to have a serious
conversation like okay here we go
and then a joke would happen or
i thought it was great the first time
and after that you know what i'm going
to talk about jay hunt
stormbreaker mjolnir oh that was just
creepy
it was
he has a love triangle thor has a love
triangle with stormbreaker mjolnir
because mjolnir is
with jane now and he's rude mjolnir to
protect her so now she's gotten the
power from the owner and it's
but you know he wants his hammer
so
which is something they joked about in
ragnarok isn't it
they joked about that that oh missing
sounds like you got a bit of a close
connection with your hammer but they
double downed on it in this movie
and they made it creepy if it was just
the stormbreaker coming around the
corner that first time whenever it's
great this door is like come here me
over here come here and then
stormbreaker kind of comes
it's hilarious but then
half a movie later he's quickly storm
breakers chin and pouring beers on top
of him so he can have a beer
while he's guiding them down a path it's
your first beer buddy here you go buddy
[Music]
yeah yeah
honestly it goes into the cringy it goes
into the like oh
i don't like it it's it goes creepy it's
not funny
uh they're
the internet talks of course but
apparently kevin feige isn't he's still
executive producer everywhere but
there's just so much on their plate
talking about quantity over quality
right now and executive produce
everything the way he used to
yeah kind of it kind of you can tell
just because it doesn't seem like he had
his finger on here to reel anything back
in and i don't want to even say that
because i want to direct and produce and
i think directors
but like
but that is definitely a point i wanted
to make out because i always felt like
when he went into thor
um ragnarok there was a bit of it it was
a marvel movie with a sprinkling of um
uh taika waititi's humor in there
whatever but it was all it always felt
like there was somebody holding him back
and i always feel like it's a bit like i
always said this about the first batman
and the second batman movies you know
the michael keaton movie with tim burton
there was the tim burton was virtually
unknown actor director sorry but it was
so popular
they basically gave him the second film
batman returns and just go we trust you
just go for it sort of thing it's it's
like that with this you know it's just
like
they
ragnarok was so great they went oh well
just go for it we trust you just go for
it and he's just absolutely blown his
load all over this movie
and it just shows you just like honestly
he just he was just allowed to do
whatever he wanted and it shows
somebody
you know
you know going back to the hit and miss
and you know i think you know again
maybe you know round five or whatever
will get some sort of direction what all
these movies are going for but it seems
like the hits
that they're having
tends to be things like you know uh
falcon in the winter soldier
moon knight which i thought was really
good
you know loki was excellent one division
i thought was really good
but it's they're more episodic and i'm
just wondering are they succeeding in
more complicated stories that require
eight ten episodes
and the one-offs just
i don't know um i can't wait for
daredevil and when they remake dead
we're gonna rip that off because that's
gonna be phenomenal
um
i i watched spiderman the last spiderman
movie last night no way home and i'm
just there watching it thinking i can't
believe i'm saying this but this is much
much better than
doctor strange two doctor strange two
was also not particularly very good
um i watched it again last week
and i just thought this is actually you
know because sometimes you're so excited
about a movie and i was really looking
forward to loving thunder you're
watching the cinema first time you know
i'm a bit disappointed but you watch it
the second time and you go no actually
this is a great film i was just i just
hyped myself up too much you know stress
so i thought i'll watch it again just to
make sure and after i'm going no
actually this just isn't very good it's
all right it's not terrible it's good in
bed it's not
it's not like the standard of what we
used to for marvel movies
but is that just because they're going
over quality over quantity is it because
they've lost their way a little bit
they're just trying to i mean because
they're they're releasing
two or three series a year and two or
three movies every year is it just too
much
and
it's covered part of the problem
if it gets any worse i'm gonna have to
go back and watching you know dc's
legends of tomorrow or something well
they canceled that one so
damn it well there's lots of older
episodes i'm sure i could enjoy before
there's a lot there's a lot yeah there's
like eight seasons though
i only watched the first few episodes of
that i thought it was rubbish because i
oh there's a iron man and then something
i can't be asked of this
um there's superman dress design man
which really confused me
um yeah
i do wish i'd carried on watching the
flash though i might have to go back to
start watching the flash again
i stopped around season four-ish i
stopped at five i wouldn't go further
come on brother
uh
i'd have to give it a go but um
again with doctor strange though me
saying about how some of the special
effects weren't very good and we'll
mention she-hulk in a minute
some of the special effects in strange
in doctor strange two are damn right
dodgy
they're like some of the um some of the
the morphin cgi when it's when it's a
person sort of thing and you can tell
jimmy like um the second
second matrix went a third matrix when
he's finding loads and loads of smiths
for the first time in that park yes
and um he looks like a clay man in bits
and yeah at the time don't get me wrong
it was it was phenomenal but you could
tell the first spider-man with toby
mcguire there's a bit which is running
across the rooftops and again you can
tell it's not quite right but they've
moved on from that it's been brilliant
for years and in doctor strange too two
or three times you're like
that's that it looks like a plasticine
man
it doesn't look like it's like the arms
are too long or something something's
not quite right it's just like the cgi
they've just not quite put as much
effort in as they have been
whether the budget's cut because they're
just or just because they're rushing it
or but if you look at she-hulk the cgi
for she-hulk i'm hoping it's just an
early render and it'll it'll be better
when it hits our screens but it's it's
bad
it's really bad
um and i just i just don't know if
that's again it's
quantity over quality i don't know
i mean
it's got to be parsley with that just
because
the vast majority of
most of the film cg in all these films
or tv shows are great we're not
complaining about all of it but there
are certain scenes that are just
it breaks the uncanny uncanny valley and
because the other scenes look so great
like in doctor strange
the morphing looks odd sometimes because
wanda crawling out of a
a
looks great that giant uh
leviathan like monster at the beginning
uh
fighting
looks pretty great it's interacting with
its environment well everything looks
good but whenever the morphing i feel
like starts it's just
you're watching a human do something and
that uncanny valley just comes back have
you ever watched the corridor crew
youtube channel
um yeah i might actually have done i've
gone
you may like them they talk a lot about
vfx they're out in l.a out here and they
do a bunch of vfx stuff they have their
own vfx house and they get
a little couch together and have people
come on their uh show
vfx art of course and adam savage has
been on there they have a lot of great
great stuff
but they'll talk about all this marvel
stuff since they're vfx people and they
had the guy that did like black widow
come on there and talk about the whole
bad scene with uh the white widow coming
out and all the explosion behind they're
not looking great and all that and
they kind of get into that aspect of
where like hey most of it's great but
look at these couple shots and those
couple shots are all that people focus
on after the fact though they stick out
like a sore thumb though don't they it's
like you notice them because they they
because they do stick out and cgi's got
so good in the last few years you don't
notice it's there a lot of the time yeah
and it's all of a sudden when it when it
does when it's not very good it really
sticks out it's like
why have you done that why didn't you
spend a little bit more time that's the
thing if an artist behind the scenes is
going to put their name on it allow them
to have the time they need i mean of
course there's a date that the
filmmakers have to meet but
[ __ ] we talked about him last week
just be a little more meticulous go
james cameron on it look at the avatar
movies like
or simplify it so that you're not having
to do that simplify the story so you're
not doing it we're supposed to be in a
rebuild phase we started you know start
to build up towards a new
galactic
villain or something so
simplify the stories a little bit you
know it's like um
the shanxi was was a lot of physical um
stunts and things instead you know so
they simplified it a little bit
they didn't need as much cgi and
even the bit when they had a dragon
fighting and massive moth or something
it looked great
moving because i mean going it went back
to a story
you know as opposed to
from what i'm hearing from you guys it
was a
thor loving thunder was a bunch of sight
gags
yep you know it wasn't a story like
it was just
maybe that's the missing thing
yeah
like i said there was a story there but
it just got drowned and
stupid jokes
drowned under love and thunder
and it ends with him now he's got a
little kid with him that's got laser
beams
coming out of her freaking eyes and even
that you just think i i don't know where
this is going
um
she could be a cool character but one
thing that
it shouldn't put a bad taste in my mouth
it's kind of funny coming from taco of
course but you know who uh that little
actress was that
played the love at the end right
i i know they're all the different
actors kids
which is great but
in the interview in
in in interview i guess tycho was saying
oh yeah we used all of our kids just to
save on cost budgets of course they do
that that's that's a funny little thing
and it's it's cheaper to use your own
kids but
if these people are going to be in
further movies don't recast hire an
actor that's there to actually do
something whether they're young
children actors in this are terrible
and then we're used to seeing children
actors that aren't particularly good
watch the first two harry potter movies
um but they they were pretty bad the um
character that somehow thor's aldo
now what's the yellow eyes uh it just
elvis character
i'm not um he's his kid in this kind of
actor [ __ ] it's just just like he's
reading that was the worst cgi right
there yeah oh oh i need to own his head
appears his floating header piece
honestly
yeah so he he projects himself stormy so
that thor can see him and then he just
think with the eyes and i'll be able to
see you and it's just
crap
um
honestly from one person chris has a
good point
in the chat room right is why people
keep saying this they have said this
since the start of the thor 11 thunder
is almost at a billion in two to three
weeks obviously the public don't have
fatigue
well you know
what what other big budget action movie
is in theaters now
the gray man
oh yeah i mean you know
there's not a lot in the theaters these
days to choose from and everyone's still
there's coveted still and everyone's you
know still wanting a reason to get out
of the house
and you know i do think people
like it
you know it's it's an afternoon
distraction
i love it
but you know it is not
i think the thing that we're bitching
about most is it doesn't
it doesn't rise to the level of other
marvel movies that did an
amazing job of telling a story yeah and
i think the rotten tomatoes score for
love and thunder is like the second or
third worst of any marvel movie so far
it's really bad yeah and but yeah i mean
but
all marvel movies basically since covid
have an amazing first week and then they
drop by 70 or 80 in their second week
and that's been a trend since um marvel
uh since covid but it's also i would
argue it's a trend since disney plus was
created and that they put the cinema
movie releases on as soon as they're off
the cinema
they're on disney plus within like a
couple of weeks i mean
already on disney plus it's insane
with my schedule i so much don't care
anymore i just wait for it to come on
disney plus and then i get off work and
we go watch it you know yeah
yeah
yeah i mean but if you love the marvel
movies you're going to go to the cinema
in the first week and i also think
before all the spoilers come out
so they're always going to have great
first weeks and there is a love for them
and i will always go to watch the marvel
movie this isn't going to put me off
because i love the and when they get it
right they're just phenomenal
um i'm not a big fan of the venom movies
and they did really really well and i
think they're incredibly badly
oh my god i love me some venom
shut your mouth
i adore but it should be better
hardy's acting is great but why what
who asked for that what is that movie
i'm still confused venom ii right
carnage
in places it's bloody awful but there's
this whole bit where venom comes in and
he sees carnage and he's oh oh god it's
a red one i'm out of here she'll be fine
okay so and then then i'm sort of like
him telling her to tell her you said no
come on we're going to save a life they
don't explain that at all
i'm interesting that seems like actually
quite an important bit of the film but
carnage is a red one so venom is scared
of him okay why haven't we mentioned
that before and actually do you want to
explain it
but they just don't they just go oh okay
i'll fight him then i'll see look at
their asses
that wasn't done by marvel studios was
it
only and marvel studios so it's not even
me by marvel but with because sony owned
venom
i don't know
they got a six-pointer
yeah i'm obvious i haven't seen morbius
yet but apparently i shouldn't bother
oh i i can i just [ __ ] about morbius
for a bit
please i
use
you know it um
my girlfriend's a big vampire kind of
genre fan and even she couldn't get with
this it was there's
god i ran jay off
anyway it was um
i didn't find it compelling i mean it's
not something that
usually
like going back to episode 4 star wars
it was compelling and you wanted to see
what the rest of the story was you know
you know even you know the prequels i
wanted to know what those stories
were i could have done without jar jar
but i still want to know what those
stories were but you know morpheus it
was like
i could care less what the next chapter
in this dude's life is
you know or what happens to the i just
didn't i had no i mean for me and you
know i i'm a movie snob i'll totally
admit it
for me it wasn't compelling enough for
me to have any type of emotional bond
with it with the main characters or any
of the sub characters or i just it was
something to watch
you know and i
i mean compared to like you're going
back again to you know uh the the marvel
uh tv series on disney plus
you know
falcon inner soldier
god what a great buddy cops series you
know
i mean start seeing such ha i mean they
uh pale in comparison
it was great acting with great writing
and they really bounced off each other
well it's kind of like how venom and tom
hardy's character bounced off each other
in the in the movie and that's the best
bit of venom yeah they're the good part
everything else everything else is
pretty bad but um
in my opinion but uh yeah i loved um
uh the scarlet witch but the first three
episodes were boring
um very clever you know you know it's
just yeah no then there's that meme with
the guy in front of the cork board with
all the pages and he's going you know
trying to explain it after after uh
episode three then it all started to tie
together like oh my god and then
everybody had this collective online
twitter orgasm like oh my god this is
the best thing since sliced bread it was
very very clever
there was some exposition they had to go
through and then they just gave you the
gut punch in in episode three and it's
just like
holy [ __ ] what's going on and the kind
of the same thing happened with loki
it's like
what the [ __ ]
and then what i just did and then
episode three is just
head on fire man i mean it was now that
is a compelling story storytelling you
you're confused you're trying to make
the sense you're trying to connect all
the lines and then they throw you
something like an episode three and it's
like
oh what's coming on episode four and
then you're so hooked
right
you cry in yours in in your bed because
you reach the end of the series
yeah that's it yeah i agree
i mean chris got the you have to judge a
series by the whole thing not a couple
of episodes and like i said
it was boring my kids got bored of it
because i didn't understand what was
going on and they got bored i kept going
uh because i watch them all i i haven't
watched miss marvel yet but apparently
i've got to because of the end is
apparently changes everything but i've
avoided the stories so i don't know what
the end is so we have to watch miss
marvel but i don't want to
it took me a while to watch moonlight
actually i found that a bit dull as well
but like i think mandalorian's the same
and all these tv series are all the same
you've got to get the first through the
first couple of episodes because there's
a lot of
story and a lot of premises
you know
here's another thing i want to bring up
concerning ms marvel
and ensures like it disney is producing
uh content
for all sorts of demographics
you know ms marvel that's a kids show
you know that that's for the that's for
a demographic
under 90210 you know
and they're targeting it for a really
young female high school crowd
you know ninth graders
it's i mean they're not writing this
[ __ ] for us
for our demographic
white male
mostly with beards
it may not
need to be appreciated by all of us
because it's not targeted for us
and
that said i think
loving thunder from listening to you
guys is definitely
aimed at
marvel fans yeah if you missed
completely they complete they didn't
they didn't just miss the target i think
they did a four one eighteen just shot
in a completely opposite direction
and shot the director in the face
my worry is
will disney let him do whatever he wants
to star wars when he does his star wars
movie will they give him free reign
because that film will stick out if they
do
it will be so different this film is
completely different to anything marvel
have ever done ragnarok was different
but it was still a marvel movie but it
was it had a bit more to it this this
loving thunder is completely different
what what the hell will he do with star
wars if he's given free reign
i don't think he's gonna that that's the
okay i'm gonna have to nuance myself to
oblivion right here because i'm hired by
disney one day uh come on i'm an actor
for hire come on but uh
don't listen to this next sentence or
two um
kathleen kennedy
she
she is
maybe not exactly what lucasfilm needs
100 of the time
um but
she is one of the things people complain
about her with i think might actually
help with tycho star wars film because i
after thor 11 thunder i am worried about
tiger star wars film and that's like i
said coming from ty is like
i'm not his number one fan but i'm up
there
people get mad at kathleen kennedy
because she kind of reigns all these
directors and people back in that are
working on their star wars projects and
kind of
makes them nonsensical in a way uh not
always rogue one was fantastic when she
kind of ranked that back in a little bit
solo kind of got
skewed a little bit with everything i
still enjoy generally a confused title
they should have they should have
scrapped the name solo and just caught
it
and then it had been fine
who doesn't want a chewy origin story
that's a secret
[ __ ] yeah i mean that would have been
great
awesome
and ignored solo
so
kathleen kennedy can kind of
ground taika a little bit
because i mean he did do the season one
finale of mandalorian yes he directed
that and he is ig 88 i believe uh no
that's 11. no 88 no he's 88 i believe i
don't remember one of the igs
um
so yeah hopefully hopefully kkk can
that's what violence
and focus is genius because if he did
what kevin feige
if if he's like to have free reign he's
like a child in a candy shop and he's
just still eat everything until he's
sick
um and we we don't need we need somebody
to rein him in we need someone to give
him a slap on the wrist and just say
that's enough now because he didn't know
they didn't have it for this movie
whenever it's raining
i think one of the big problems with
solo for me is that it was just bad
casting as well just that's my two cents
on solo i actually don't think it's a
bad movie i don't think it's badly
written i think it's it's it's you know
if you if you could close your eyes and
listen to it it's not a bad film but i
think they've got the casting all wrong
and it's um and that was one of the
reasons why we loved solo so much was
because
they got the casting right you know it
was um
and
that's for me anyway just i just thought
they got it wrong from day one
i thought he did all right but there was
a
i forget the movie but there was a movie
where harrison ford had a guy play a
younger version of himself and that guy
was
i think the second runner up for solo
river phoenix in no because river
phoenix is dead
i was going to say river phoenix played
him in the last crusade
for when he played the young
uh oh no this was right
this was like 2014 or something oh okay
uh it was like right during casting
process and this guy was almost cast in
solo but they went with alden ehrenreich
i think is how you say his name and i i
thought he did all right that's that
that's a monumental task to
so i step into
did all right
but the other guy probably would have
embodied he was already used to
embodying harrison ford
yeah harrison ford is han solo so yeah
exactly it's very hard to follow up
which is why i don't think they should
they shouldn't have bothered they
shouldn't have tried it was it was a bad
idea from beginning to end and star wars
origins was a bad idea
and then we're going to take it the more
crimson dawn route and go the mall
stories from the get-go
[Music]
if maul would have made it in the third
act and he didn't even need to be there
to fight or anything like that because
who who would he fight with the
lightsabers no one
but
if if i guess he would have been an
overarching character to make amelia
clark's character actually have that
kind of
push and pull in her own like mental
forget about that movie i love i mean
that but she's so forgettable on that
phone she's good but there's there's no
reason she's there besides maul and then
the fact that they never brought them
all back i guess kind of it dilutes your
character now that film got really
confusing halfway through uh chris has
asked does star wars need to be single
story or can it stay in a truly format
because i think it's been mixing it up
for ages or isn't it since star wars
came back they were doing individual
stories but will there be another
trilogy
i don't even know what time frame we're
in with star wars at the moment
um when is solo set is is obi-wan set at
the same time as mandalorian
mandalorians five years after return of
the jedi
ob1 is 10 years after revenge of the
sith
and 10 years before
a new hope
i'm so confused
i've never been as big a star wars fan
as i've always been a trekkie and a
gator i'm not i'm like i know my star
trek in my star wars i don't really know
my star wars but the time frame i wish
they would just go straight cause i'm so
confused on what i'm watching
i look i do enjoy the tvs i actually
enjoy the tv series of star wars more
than i enjoy the films
have you ever dove into the animated
aspects of star wars yeah i like but i
really love bad batch
okay did you watch or rebels
yes i uh i watch most of it that's so
it's still on my list
rebels is
i think
season one is a little iffy just because
it is it's tv y7 it's for children
children uh
but by season two all the story that
they've put in and then they include
some clone wars characters seasons two
through four of rebels might be my
favorite star wars content there is and
i'm a star wars just fanatic all day
yeah i'm i'm working my way through uh
clone clone wars and troop rebel
it's just a lot to get through and i get
sidetracked and
yeah like i said i hadn't finished
league of legends yet
but before we we check out and uh
there's one thing this is kind of
tangential to this i mean it's a pixar
issue
and a lot of times on this channel we
talk about woke [ __ ] yeah you know there
there's this big uh we don't want to we
keep being made too
yeah we're forced yes and and this time
uh disney disney is doing it to us
through pixar in light year
you know i have not seen light year
but i'll probably see it streaming as
opposed to the theater because
in about a week it's not going very well
it's gonna be on disney plus next week
so
you know the the um
the the issue comes up with who is
playing lightyear you know
who is uh
and that is chris
what is it chris evans
i thought it was captain kirk played him
for a second it's not chris pine or
chris pine
right right right so
you know tim allen
you know did an admiral job in toy story
one two three four
did a very good job
but disney did not invite him back
to do lightyear to voice lightyear and
lightyear is
the
the real life
uh personage i guess of what the toy
became
but everyone says you know it was um
it was because tim allen is a
conservative and wokeness killed tim
allen's chance to play lightyear
and that's just not true
so you guys
you know how much it costs to make a
pixar film right it's about 100 to 150
million dollars to make it 150. then
it's another 100 150 to market that's
300 million dollars you have to
get in box office before you make a
dollar
now toy story did very very well billion
movies all the time but there's an
ensemble cast and let's all face it tom
hanks
is the lead character
and uh if you look at tim allen's uh box
office
the last few films
hale won
uh just a few years ago made four
thousand dollars
worldwide box office tim allen and since
galaxy toy quest almost 20 years ago
has not been a box office draw i mean
santa claus was about 20 years ago
and he hasn't really brought the box
office in for anybody
in almost two decades
you know and so
how in the world as a business decision
how in the world are you going to
fund or or chance 300 million dollars on
an actor that really hasn't been able to
carry a movie in 20 years
because i should always remember as well
that and it's not the disney hate tim
allen because they are doing a
santa claus tv series this this tv
series
has anything to do with it honestly
oh let's look at uh echo who played echo
right
from
marvel from yeah from uh oh oh uh in the
tv show in hawkeye
no no no
let's go back to uh guardians of the
galaxy
right right
so and i'm blanking on the guy's name
i can't remember who where the character
we haven't seen echo
echo is in hawkeye for a little bit
let's see
maybe uh ego sorry oh yeah
okay
okay so
is just as conservative as tim allen i
mean he uh
kurt russell and saying and goldie hawn
they both uh campaign for george w bush
they're both you know
conservative same kind
but kurt russell can definitely carry a
film
right
and
not only did they make him a villain i
think they're he's in talks with disney
for another
another appearance of him as the villain
in another uh
in another branch of the marvel universe
and that's a lot of trust
number one santa movie on netflix
kurt russell i was chronicles
and so here they got two conservative
guys
kurt russell can bring in the box office
without i mean he has been a
disney fixture for like ever always
bringing in the box first movie i
remember him was the
computer that wore tennis shoes or
something like that
and i mean he he he's a box office draw
tim allen just isn't he isn't anymore
now i do wonder why they
brought in chris evans who hasn't
exactly got a distinctive voice
he's not known for his voice acting
now it's got slightly a wooden voice
really it's not distinctive so i i don't
question why you don't why you don't get
tim allen to do it the other thing is i
think they were trying consciously to
separate this movie from
that's that i think that was the main
reason why they didn't go with tim allen
was because they wanted that separation
this is a different
product
this is a different political because
they're using tim allen across disney
plus right now uh for the things here
yeah the it's
i won't say anything about the movie i
did see it opening i guess the day after
opening day
uh
i liked it didn't love it i liked it i
thought it was a
a lot of people say the first act was
amazing
totally agree second and third act it
dil it just delves down a little bit
uh
but
the film literally starts because that's
how it really differentiates itself it
starts with the words popping up on
screen
in 1995
andy from toy story went to go see a
movie and then we he got his buzz
lightyear toy after that and yada yada
this was that movie
i've heard
this was the reboot of that movie and
that's what someone should have said at
the beginning of that film they should
have said this was the reboot of the
movie andy went to go see because this
is just not something that would have
been made in the 90s there's nothing
that would have been made in the 90s it
would be a great sci-fi film for right
now but it's not you know what in a way
i wish they'd done it in the style of
the 90s in that case why don't they do
it like that and and you know
um because that would have you know make
it a bit retro something like that would
have been a laugh
apparently this was just a sci-fi script
that pixar had and didn't have like
they couldn't come up with the right
characters in their mind i guess to
make it its own film so they put it into
i guess the story toy story mythos
um and it works to a degree
but it decanonizes my my favorite buzz
lightyear tv show from when i was a
little kid so uh
well absolutely but i love the buzz
lightyear's tv show
um it absolutely has bombed anyway it's
been pretty much destroyed at the box
office so
um
it's done okay but not what they were
expected not what they were hoping
it is a good sci-fi movie
yeah it's not gonna get anywhere near
the billion dollar mark which seems to
be the standard nowadays just whether
it's something successful or not but
um
yeah it's it's a shame but you know i
don't i don't think politics came into
it with tim allen i think is
it's drink driving and things like that
might have come into it a little bit it
could have been a little bit but they've
put him into a kids show for christmas
so
he's one of the biggest draws on tv in
america still in the world still uh so
he's still got he doesn't have a box
office draw but his tv draw is big yeah
i mean like he's great at television
he's great at that slapstick kind of uh
episodic television
uh you know he's really good at it i'm
not trying to down on him but i think it
wasn't woke anything as we've always
discussed we look at these issues it's
not wokeness here we had you know pixar
okay do we spend 300 million on somebody
whose worldwide box office last year was
four thousand dollars yeah
no exactly everybody wanted to keep
their job at disney apparently and said
no to out and picked up chris evans
who's had billions and billions and
billions of box office draws and
successes even though he may not like
the stories
i would agree
he raked it in
yeah
and clearly he can carry a movie by
himself
yeah i just i just i don't think he
stands out in this i don't think he's a
voice actor
some actors just to voice actors you
know they can they can really if you
think like tim curry um you know he's
he
was in some great movies don't get me
wrong and he's a great actor but really
if you look at his imdb it's 99 cartoons
and things because of his voice
you know he's he's he had this this
distinctive incredible voice that's just
you know as great as anything
huh clancy brown's another guy like that
gracie brown yeah
yeah some actors have just got the voice
and i don't i don't think chris evans
has
um but i can't wait to see gray man i
can't see there's another netflix
project which looks great as well so i
will watch that very shortly chris evans
excels whenever because his voice is his
voice you know
he doesn't really play with it too much
even when he does voice acting but
physicality wise he he'll play anything
that guy's great the physicality and the
gray man he brings it and does it fit
buzz like this character is like a jock
sort of thing and yes it probably does
so so does disney really want to divide
the audience
or is disney
realizes they've got a thousand
different audiences all around the world
kids shows adult shows
are they just making content for
different segments of the demographic
men women children
and even just because it's in the marvel
universe doesn't mean it's made for
everybody right i would actually operate
they're not purposely dividing it they
realize that the world is divided up in
little different sections that are
people that have different type of
interests
if anything like i say one of the
biggest arguments against disney's a lot
of the time they they do try to make
products for everybody
far too often
and that that you know they need to make
you couldn't see something like the boys
on disney i don't think but maybe i
think with the streaming service now
they are realizing that they don't have
to cookie cutter everything you know
that they can actually make some stuff
that's a bit more out of the box and
people will like it
um
and then maybe
entering there
yeah you know disney's never going to
make another song of the south and maybe
that's a good
um
yeah exactly
okay i think we've smacked on marvel
enough what do you think the future of
marvel is because i mean these things do
go around in um
in phases
at the moment everything is superheroes
there's another we've got another couple
of like real superheroes sylvester
stallone's doing it old man
yeah
actually looks really good
uh there's somebody else has done one as
well there's a couple coming out that
there seems to be a steady stream of
these if superheroes were real movies
the boys is obviously you know a
different take on that but you know very
popular moment but
yeah you know will will this is there a
cycle to these things do you think
marvel fatigue is going to happen
because people will just get bored of it
eventually it will become second
i don't know
hear us correct me if i'm wrong but it
seems like
most of the blockbusters these days and
by these days i mean the last two
decades has really been comic book
driven
you know it seems like a lot of these
story even
dead is a comic started as a comic book
and
and it just seems like the ideas of
hollywood
isn't really hollywood it's coming from
the comic book stores and the the nerds
in the comic book stores are 10 years
ahead of everybody else i'm just
wondering i just want to get your take
on that harris
no
i mean that's what hollywood had always
been whether it be books or comic books
now we've really been into comic books
and
it helps because you have i guess almost
with comics an endless supply of comics
to just draw from and
to emulate from and to
mess around with and make it make sense
in the world that they're making and
creating
um but yeah uh
i
i don't know i i i
it feels great when
something so original comes out that you
know like a filmmaker actually wrote
that like okay a christopher nolan movie
or a tarantino movie there's a reason
that feels so special because it's not
adapted and tarantino does adapt things
too
[Music]
and then i guess that's that's what
makes those films so special but
everything's always just been on those
adaptations and i think comics are
not easier to adapt but you literally
get the visual alongside the uh
auditory unless you're audio booking it
but yeah alongside your reading which
gives you what to think about and i
think that's a lot easier to translate
from page to film which is just the last
20 years
as
everyone's got a camera in their hand
now
anybody can make it and i guess it's
just kind of helping that influx of
content helping or hurting i guess
quality over quantity it brings that
into a whole much larger scale of
conversation there
uh
yeah no it's yeah that's true
there's so many different genres in
comic books i i don't have any problem
with the fact that comic books are being
tapped for these things because there's
they're not just superheroes are they
there's so many different genres yeah
like you said there's the walking dead
there's there's marvel stuff if you want
to there's sin city over here there's
all kinds of different things uh
i mean it's
if you didn't even see some of these
movies of course are making their own
comic books now i i may or may not have
pre-ordered it
but james bernard is releasing i think
two or three no a series of six comics
that tie into avatar way of water right
before it
yeah
so avatar i'm just gonna say this that
avatar way of the water is either going
to be phenomenal or awful and there's
nothing in between
yeah i know a lot of people are really
excited about it but i think the only
thing that really made avatar stand out
was the 3d and obviously i don't think
it will be in 3d this time so
we'll have to see how it works but um
i just can't bet against james cameron
yeah no he's well
i still think the
the underwater one what was it called my
head
abyss thank you the abyss is still one
of the greatest movies i've ever made
you can't even think oh hi what a
phenomenal success titanic was and all
this sort of thing the abyss is a better
film the abysses
told you about the corridor crew channel
a minute ago huh
yeah so they had the guy that did the
vfx for that
okay yesterday on their couch he did the
uh the scorpion king shot and uh just in
mummy returns as well so they were kind
of they're going back and forth like you
get too good stuff you did some bad
stuff let's you know don't do that again
so that's entertaining if you ever want
to go watch that that's that's good was
his answer for that folks they only gave
me 25 pounds to do it
and it was because i heard that the
budget for that was in the toilet days
of dwayne johnson
all of filming they needed a day alone
of just scanning his face and they had
three days of just filming in general
before
he wasn't massively famous at the time
that was the thing that that nearly
discovered his career because that film
was so bad
um
i always thought i always i i remember
thinking brendan frazier in like
california kind of stuff because if they
get him in the right action movie he'll
be he could be one of the next big
action stars because he can do the
comedy he could he can be like the new
bruce willis like a younger bruce willis
he can do a bit cheeky and do everything
but he can also do the action and when
the mummy came out i adored it and then
his career just went far
and then he started eating heavily yeah
i don't know what happened i'm i'm
interested in the whale he's in a new
darren arfanovsky film called the whale
he's playing the scene he's phenomenal
apparently he's scary goodnight
i um it what was the emdc thing he was
in recently
something or background
don't watch it but i read a lot of the
stories about it and apparently the
director and all the other actors and if
they were just going mad over just he's
the nicest man in the world he's
phenomenal actor is it anything like
that it's like where's his career been
then
because he did he needs all the roads
but it's like
where's george of the jungle six you
know like i don't know i don't need to
make some money dude you know something
yeah it's a shame because he's just such
a likable actor he's only those really
likable actors and i said the mummy
should have been but the problem is it
which is what they always do with the
bloody hollywood driving up the wall
they have a surprise hit
so they rush a sequel
and they've done it over and over and
over again
surprise hit must have a sequel out
within two years and it's just like it's
too
quick
you know it's like um a predator they
had um they had a they had a script for
predator
um but they said no we've got to do it
quick so they did they did predator do
in the city and actually i don't think
it's a bad movie but
the film they had ready
would have been it would have been much
better but you know there's every single
time they do it over and over again yeah
yorkshire geek got it right in chat yeah
he was in doom patrol
patrol too yeah yeah yeah
i do like do do patrol i haven't watched
it but everyone that has tells me to
it's supposed to be great
yeah it is a weird show
but yeah again he's supposed to be
phenomenal in that as well yeah it's
just like saying i kind of um one of the
younger kids that he's he acted with
said that she's like he feels like she's
his um he's his actor dad she's her
actor dad she says just he's just
loveable and he's so giving and he's so
you know he's just a really really nice
guy she couldn't say nice about him but
i like that i like it when you hear
stories about these guys that actually
aren't dicks they're actually genuine
you hear the same about like robert
downey jr and people like this as well
they're just and they don't go around
you know self-publicizing that how
brilliant they are
everyone else just goes this is such
nice people they go back home and work
you know it's endearing
yeah exactly
right okay so i'm happy we've covered
that and um marvel if you're listening
sort yourselves out
um and and go back to the formula all of
your stuff was very formulaic before and
then you started to do something
different and it's all going to pop but
that hey we can't love everything
um
i think chris made a good point a little
while ago about um that
that marvel are trying now to do
different types of thing because they
have been they have been said that you
know everything is all formulaic and
very similar
so they're trying to do different things
the problem is that all those different
things have to intertwine with each
other still so we're having a little bit
of a problem with it making sense but
yeah what are you going to do
yeah the next film would be great or
terrible
the last three have been terrible um we
just gotta work our way to secret wars
slowly but surely that's what i think
we're working to
hulk um uh hulk planet what's it called
i did just say world war oak i think
that's supposed to be
san diego comic con next week so i think
that might be announced next week i'm
hoping for things that we should
probably do actually we might have to we
have got a sort of a plan for next week
we might have to do a comic con special
because i think there'll be a lot
announced
so we'll have to see how the week goes
um
i
said jose
did i like boba fett i did like boba
fett
um
but my favorite two boba fett episodes
are the two episodes he wasn't in
um when the mandalorian took over they
were great
um
as soon as boba fett showed up and stood
in the background brilliant
um but the in the last episode was weird
but um but yeah like
that boba fett the most was the
backstory in the origin story actually
of the same people
yeah i
wish you know i mean they had a complete
culture always under our nose we never
knew anything about it
and it was like god that's how the
[ __ ] dune sea came about you know
well i thought it was really strong
storytelling and i also think that um
boba fett tied up a lot of things in
earlier episodes of
episodes that
that just was not explained anywhere
else and i thought this was you know
since he got swallowed by the sarlacc
that it was like a really good way to
fill in a lot of those holes and yeah it
did it added a lot to the law
you knew i mean you know it was just
no wonder i watched one more project of
star wars on tatooine though i'm going
to lose my mind there's like three
million planets in that damn universe
can we visit more than two
oh yeah and then of course kevin brings
up
stargate
well i might have just done a video on
stargate and we mentioned kurt russell
there are heavy rumors
that there will be a stargate movie
starring kurt russell
now this these rumors were started by
giant freaking robot and i didn't
believe in them when i did a video going
[ __ ]
whoever does their channel
yeah
at least please look but never i
actually spoke to a couple of people
that know about these things and they've
said it's possible actually this might
be possible but this was something that
was actually talked about like seven
years ago and went as far as being green
lit
that they were going to do a kurt
russell james spader sequel to the
original movie in 2015
but it got cancelled pretty quick and
then about two years after that they
considered it again and rolling denmark
came out about eight months eight nine
months ago saying that they're having
conversations again
but he but he feels that he doesn't want
to do it because he feels like the tv
audience is what's the priority
and which is which is what i'm being
told from amazon they don't want to piss
too many people off by just doing a hard
reboot
um so they're gonna i think they're
gonna try to do some sort of
mishmash where they can get kurt russell
in a movie but sg1 sgu and sga still
happened
and we'll see if they do it right it
could be great
but i think they're just hoping that
people won't care if the film's good
i don't know
i
i i went to the imax premiere of
moonfall where roland emmerich sat down
and and my favorite show
talked about after it wasn't the best
but it was it was entertaining
especially with him in the theater i
guess in the imax it was all right after
the fact i watched again but after the
question i answered after the fact he
said uh
he doesn't want anything to do with
stargate
at all
yeah
that's one of the things he says that
he's contractually obliged he might have
to come back if they do a movie
um but that's one of the things is they
say that's only if they do a cinematic
movie if it just goes straight to prime
he's not contractually obliged to do
anything
so he doesn't have to come up but he did
not seem keen to come back he didn't
even want to seem to talk about stargate
he was there to do a moonball interview
and they kept talking about stargate
yeah [ __ ]
maybe a little bit
uh you know i i
i kind of liked it you know the concepts
of it yeah you know
you know and little uh disenfranchised
scientists i love elon
best move line in the film
that was great
it just got sillier and sillier is it
one time
yeah yeah
um it started off really well and it
started off quite interesting but i knew
where it was going yeah and i was
thinking all the way through i'm like
this is hollow moving through oh god
somebody's been watching ancient aliens
again and um
and it's just great i think bed knobs
and broomsticks made more sense than
[Music]
yeah
definitely
reach halloween there
yeah it was just terrible
um but it was better than the
independence day resurgence that's the
truth well i don't
we don't even need to talk about that
one i'm going to start having an
aneurysm
oh my god it was like the whole thing
was some sort of homage to will smith
who wasn't in it and they they got so
tingled up with that line of legacy he's
just like
could he fallen down the stairs and died
and no one mentioned him you know i mean
his character
it's just moved oh god i mean
i did like that
oh yes the special effects were
phenomenal nobody else noticed though
either that in that if that if if if
that film was true and that massive
planet-sized thing landed on the earth
and started messing with that gravity
even if we defeat it the earth would be
[ __ ]
i mean could you imagine look what we've
done with a few cars what would that
thing do to our economy
we'd have to be moving we'd have to be
like guys we got to move
because this thing has to gouge three
enormous holes in the planet and screwed
our gravity up this is like they may
know and then that whole scene at the
end was just sort of like
did they run out of money and just
couldn't be asked
the the enemy of the the grays
i mean there was an enemy to the great i
liked that and that you know that would
have
you know
getting them into the game would
would have been cool you know i'm so i'm
guessing you know like the the enemy of
the greys was
you know hurled in the infor you know
pushing them forward out into the galaxy
and they just kind of ran over us maybe
or
i mean there were lots of there was lots
of good meaty stuff they could have
gone into and didn't the only the best
redeeming thing about it is that the
grades didn't have an enemy and jeff
goldblum i thought was still a pretty
good at it
yeah jeff goldman still but jeff glover
just plays griff goldblum and evan
doesn't he just turns up and makes
everybody laugh the best part
i remember watching resurgence and the
end of resurgence is all about let's
make a tv show and that's what the end
of the resurgence is just like if we if
this does well we'll get to make a tv
show and that's what they were basically
setting up and i'm not watching the guy
yeah you ain't gonna hang out when
you're in the tv show
has anyone actually brought up you know
uh something on uh
an episodic show on streaming
based on id4
oh god i hope not well if they're based
on id4 not resurgence maybe
but i've i don't i've not seen that one
myself
i i am going to just question alien and
pace who look
we've spoken to aliens in space before
he's really good batman's not a good
movie
um one
it's a fun movie it's a popcorn dude
it's a movie
it is a film where they've gone we want
to make a film about the battleship game
i go okay but the battleship game
doesn't really work and it's illogical
because they're all things like no
you will set the rules of this game and
you will make a movie and they're like
oh [ __ ] how are we going to do that
and and so they're big shields and
everything in the and the the weapons
that look like the white heart you know
it's not a good one and the whole bit at
the end where they just go and get the
missouri out of everything and then if
if you ever only film and you're the
best thing in it is rihanna you're in
trouble
and then put his next comment and again
i'm not mocking you any space because i
really do love you and i hope to have
you on the show but gods of egypt was
really not good
i turned it off after 45 minutes because
the special effects were so bad and the
story made no logical sense to me at all
i'm almost so super sarcastic
too
i thought it was unpredictable it wasn't
kind of like ibs
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry no pun intended
i've not seen it in 4k but maybe i say
maybe it'd be better in 4k but the
effects in thing was but i i have to
admit i i kind of like the look of gods
of egypt but i had to turn it off it was
just
not very good
but but hey it's all opinion and if the
another day if we
had to the oh yeah making a handbrake
turn
but if we all liked the same things at
the end of the day it would make life
very boring but i will say that it was
fun
it's one of those i always say i love a
good film i love a good action movie
things like this where it's popcorn in
hand turn off brain and just
i'm really special
but even even battleship made my
yeah well it made my turn off brain
still go wait what
and and this is a film that you know
this is a brain that doesn't really turn
on for most most things i don't see
twists coming because i just go into i
just enjoy the movie i don't think about
it too much
um but even that i'm sort of going i'm
not sure this is realistic
why would they do it that way
anyway
so battleship was awesome we were wrong
it was awesome oh i hate it i i didn't
hate it
yeah i just don't want to watch it again
um
yeah actually to be fair and aliens
supposed to ears right they're actually
the aliens in in battlefield were quite
cool
um i just and you know the other thing
there's like all of the um all the vets
in that i quite i quite liked that but i
thought they went too far with it yeah i
did i like that they did seen
with brooklyn decker up there fighting
all the aliens but then
half a scene later he's beating aliens
with his leg and i was like all right
went a little bit too far a little
farther the shark
no pun intended
yeah
it's no goofier than thor 11 thunder
that's for damn sure battleship is ten
times more serious than thor love and
thunder i can tell you that much all day
i actually think battleship might have
made more sense than them
doesn't have screaming goats every 45
seconds
oh that's part of the new part
of the movie or love and thunder just
for the screaming goats if it's every 40
seconds i'm into that [ __ ] it's not
every 40 seconds
it's it's repeatedly do you know the bit
the you know the bit they do in ragnarok
they did a bit with matt damon do you
remember that stormy when they did the
plane ending to the thing right they
redo that and they do that scene again
and they're doing a bit from ragnarok
um and they do it that the acting in
that is better than the rest of the film
oh because it's still
matt damon and then you know the guy
that plays thor is just the older
hemsworth brother from west yeah
so it's just looking worth it and then
hello was great
they got yeah melissa mccartney
i like how they did the the munya going
across the screen and it's on a string
and then she sort of like goes that slow
catches something that was quite good
but i quite like that but even that
that scene was way too long
um and like i said the acting was it's
supposed to be wooden bad acting but
it's it was on a par with the rest of
the film you could barely notice the
difference i i do want to point out to
you exactly yeah
i just want to point out that
while you're repeating talking about
that one scene both of you were giggling
like children just saying
yeah they're all legitimately great
hilarious parts of that film i'm not
feeling the hate
i'm just not feeling the hate no no
there are bits of that film i absolutely
adore there are it's just too much of it
that's the problem the humor is good
there's just too much of it wouldn't it
would have been better as a episodic tv
show
seriously serious question would that
have been with the plot and all the gags
there that would have made better as a
no no no
you know what could be there it might
have done because it would have had a
different atmosphere maybe and it it
they could have stretched it out a bit
so i mean the idea apparently the first
cut of this film was four hours
and they had to go
like if it would have gone a
that not batman vs superman uh zack
snyder's justice league kind of route
and maybe like have
four parts and split each one into like
not you can have it release it as a film
but make it where you can kind of go
back and
pause it or something like that and
watch little bits at a time four films
or four longer episodes the tv would
have felt a lot better
yeah
and i think it would have been you could
have almost mentally
separated it a little bit from the rest
of the universe
so it might it might have worked better
in a way as well i i look forward to
thor coming out though on um disney plus
because i will watch it again i was
really really looking forward to this
film
but i still think i'm going to come away
with thinking that big parts of this
film were just really really creepy and
him there go you know the bit where he's
got the guardians the galaxy are leaving
and they just want to go
right they just want to get out there
because he's such a pain in the ass and
they should have
gone more with that
even um star lord was a little bit
creepy in that there's this bit where
you're still again just you know be with
the one you love and then like falling
there weren't you with
sorry i think and there's something in
that there's this guy going this is a
big guy
and it's just like you know so and
nothing nothing against that at all i
have no problem with yeah you know men
lovingly i don't care or think but jay
jay
maybe it wasn't gay enough
maybe maybe they could have got i'll
tell you what it was another type of
stuff did it move you into your room too
but it didn't move me anywhere stormy
calm down
but it wasn't it wasn't um again it's
not the right word and i feel like i'm
digging myself into a hole here but yes
you are and we're glad to help
[Music]
i wanted a team-up film i knew i wasn't
gonna get a full team up film but i
wanted a guardian then there for at
least like maybe leave during the second
act and they come back and need to help
during the third act or something
and valkyrie was crap as well and that's
annoying because she was the best
character from rank rock she was amazing
i loved her magnoc and she was underused
in this film and it's a shame because
they put
um jane fonda in the front row that was
quite a good joke i quite like that one
and they put her in the front and thing
and and valkyrie was a bit i almost wish
they'd left valkyrie out really um but
the whole gods thing was the worst bit
that's the worst bit but anyway we would
have had that four hour like episodic
kind of version of it i think the gods
could have been
we could have gotten the best marvel
thing possible with that honestly just
if the jokes were spread out because
honestly
every single joke is funny
every single joke lands but just the
amount of them
it cringe it makes you cringe a little
bit
thinking about individual jokes is great
because that makes that makes us laugh
we're laughing like nobody's business
about it but there's no build up to it
there is there like the the great scene
in ragnarok when the hulk
because hey i know him from work
it's annoying that the joke was in the
bloody advert
um but you know uh which the trailer
sorry which that really bugged me
but there's no there's no build up to
any of the jokes they're just sort of
like choke choke choke choke and there's
no build up to anything that's the
problem it's edited one of my favorite
build-up jokes in ragnarok was the whole
wolf and hulk at the end just
the whole fight the entire thing the
hulk smashing in as a person or as bruce
banner first then coming back it's the
whole because and
same thing almost with the the wolf
after that's great but it's got an
entire film
of build
anyway let's call it x that's been an
hour and a half stormy
that was my fault we hit an hour and i
asked a question and we
there we go
so completely stole me i think you're
you're a bad influence on me sir i'm
blaming you when the wife says maybe
being blaming you
but
hey we're here for the for the for the
audience that's what we want we're here
for you guys to entertain you and to you
know
stuff
so
have the lovely rest of the day my
american friends um i'm gonna go and sit
in a cold bath
um
because i sweaty in places i don't want
to be sweaty and i've not got air
conditioning
so i'm gonna
but harrison stormy thank you very much
for and
please go over and um subscribe to
stormy's channel
harris i might not have yours in the
description
sorry um but i will sort it out for you
movies marijuana
yeah but i will get you on the
description for surely but please guys
go over subscribe to both of these
american idiots um
wanna be an american idiot
he i think he renounced his uh
citizenship and he's now canadian or
something
why would it be
green day
oh i think it was here
something like there's an old joke back
in the day because there any americans
that go traveling around the world just
pretend you're a canadian
yes
yeah see i look out because i'm texting
so i just say i'm from texas they're
like oh that's that different place
yeah
it's like america and then texas and
then there's new york and la that's all
they get
down a lot in airports as soon as they
go texas i wonder who's getting the uh
the pat down in this of this flight
surprisingly now when i leave texas yes
usually i'm not in texas
if you're not packing three weapons
you're likely armed and you're in texas
i think and if you're not packing three
weapons they will give you one at the
border
yeah
like
like when you hand down hawaii they give
you a thing of flowers
in texas they get uh would you like to
see
but you gotta buy it we'll give you a 30
discount though yeah
we're from the world country we got to
make some cash you know
exactly but anyway we're just waffling
on there guys
really as always thank you so much we
will see you next week for a complete of
talking maybe we will do comic con let's
see what gets announced really looks
like that um but as i say thank you so
much for joining and uh say goodbye guys
goodbye guys see yah
i've done it again this week that i've
got an outro and i keep forgetting to
found it
[Music]